und was wir vor allem brauchen ist auch
ein bisschen hoffnung mit blick wie das
jahr weitergeht und deswegen wollen wir
jetzt einmal auf unsere karte schon auf
unser krone radar und sollte mal die
zahlen der hoffnung anschauen ich starte
da einmal mit einer zahl 60 ist nicht
etwas was hoffnung stiften ist wie einen
neuen höchstwert erreicht und zwar bei
der sieben tage incidents sie liegt bei
53,2 der neuen höchstwert in der
pandemie dass aber diese karte hier die
macht hoffnung denn sie sehen hier ist
ganz ganz vieles grün neun bundesländer
sind es die bei der hospitalisierung
since it ends und das ist ein ganz
entscheidender wert in dieser krise
unter dem grenzwert von 3 liegen werden
uns diese maßnahmen sind gestaffelt
werden hier mehrere grenzwerte schon
sich die karte an neuen bundesländer
sind grün den geringsten wert hat
sachsen mit 2,0 ein bundesland das so
sehr gebeutelt war von der korona ins
von der korona lage in deutschland ihre
spezialisierung sin city zeigt an wie
viele menschen gerechnet auf 100000
einwohner in den vergangenen sieben
tagen mit corona im krankenhaus
behandelt werden im krankenhaus gelandet
sind und dieser wert der sinkt und das
ist etwas was hoffnung macht schauen wir
hier ganz genau reihen sie schauen wir
mal auf die gelben orte da diese über
dem grenzwert von 3 das bedeutet dass
hier maßnahmen wie zweig dann ziehen und
dann geht es weiter dann zieht zweig
plus brenzlig da ist es hier oben zwei
bundesländer haben wir da liegen die
werte darüber die sind rot und orange
besonders angespannt die lage in bremen
mit einer spezialisierung des instituts
von 11,7 und hier in mecklenburg
vorpommern
6,15 haben wir hier ansonsten aber neun
bundesländer im grünen bereich bei der
hospitalisierung incidents ganz
entscheidend ist die situation ist die
lage in den krankenhäusern auch auf den
intensivstationen in dieser krise und
hier sehen wir eben auch den effekt von
omikron dass alle forscher was alle
virologen sagen sehr sehr ansteckend
aber die erkrankten eben nicht so
gravierend deswegen hier schauen sie auf
diese grün bundesländern sind es an der
zahl wo wir unter drei ligen und die
zahl die singt wie gesagt weiter
insgesamt liegen wir bei deutschland bei
3,17 zum vergleich gestern lagen wir
noch bei 3,6 7 die situation in den
krankenhäusern die wollen wir uns jetzt
weiter an schauen und damit wieder
zurück zu teilweise
und über diese zahlen wollen wir weiter
sprechen patricia danke dir das tun wir
mit gerald gaß dem chef der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft schönen guten
tag herr gast
die zahlen sagen uns dass sich die lage
in den krankenhäusern deutlich entspannt
müssen also die krankenhäuser endlich
nicht mehr total am limit arbeiten
wir hoffen das sehr und auch ich bin
verhalten zuversichtlich was die
nächsten tagen und wochen angeht wir
haben ja nach wie vor sinkende zahlen
auf den intensivstationen und nur in
einigen regionen im moment steigende
zahlen aus den normalen stationen aber
auch wir können bestätigen dass
offensichtlich die schweren verläufe mit
dieser virusvariante abgenommen haben
bedeutet das dass jetzt pflegepersonal
das jetzt erste vielleicht auch endlich
mal so weit kommen die über stunden die
sie aufgebaut haben die belastung der
sie ausgesetzt waren ein bisschen
abzubauen haben wir diesen punkt bereits
erreicht
an dem punkt sind wir leider noch nicht
das liegt aber nicht nur an romy cohen
oder jetzt an der pandemie sondern es
liegt sozusagen an den langfristigen
folgen wir haben ja viele patienten
patienten auf die wartelisten nehmen
müssen in den verschiedenen wellen auch
zuletzt und natürlich geht es jetzt
darum diese patientinnen und patienten
zu behandeln das heißt wir bestellen die
patienten jetzt ein und insofern zeit
für überstunden abbau ist leider noch
nicht aber wir hoffen sehr dass wir dann
im frühjahr etwas entspanntere zeiten in
den krankenhäusern erleben und wir
wünschen uns allen normalität rechnen
sie damit dass wir jetzt in den nächsten
wochen den nächsten monaten das ende der
pandemie erleben werden
da kann ich auch nur das wiedergeben was
wir von den biologen hören wir hoffen
dass ich bin grundsätzlich optimist in
meiner persönlichkeit und insofern
wünsche ich mir das auch allerdings muss
ich leider sagen wir haben erlebt dass
wir immer wieder überraschten von neuen
entwicklungen und insofern im moment
kann ich nur sagen es sieht gut aus aber
so ganz genau weiß ich natürlich auch
nicht was in den nächsten monaten noch
kommen könnte ich habe noch eine frage
gast zu den zahlen die wir gerade
gesehen haben zu dieser karte der
hoffnung die mittlerweile fast überall
grün ist besonders grün ist sie in
sachsen aktuell dort war die kranken aus
lage so angespannt im jahr ende
vergangenen jahres hat man ja von dort
patienten ausgeflogen nach nordrhein
westfalen nach hamburg und so weiter
mittlerweile die beste hospitalisierung
des instituts auch insgesamt die
niedrigsten instanzen wie erklären sie
das
ja das liegt sicherlich daran dass wir
zum einen doch in der letzten welle
viele menschen hatten die sich
angesteckt haben leider dadurch ist
natürlich auch eine gewisse
immunisierung jenseits des impfens
entstanden und der zweite effekt ist
sicherlich auch im rahmen dieser hohen
instanzen zuletzt gab es natürlich auch
massive kontakt beschränkungen und
vorsichtsmaßnahmen die bevölkerung hat
mitgemacht sie hat erlebt in der letzten
welle wie dramatisch die lage in sachsen
war und das hat uns jetzt dort geholfen
und hat ja auch in deutschland insgesamt
geholfen wir stehen ja etwas besser da
als andere staaten die weniger kontakt
beschränkungen weniger
vorsichtsmaßnahmen haben und hatten und
insofern waren das gute entscheidungen
in der vergangenheit hat sie dann gerald
gaß chef der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft bei bild live
dank ihn dann gewann sie jemand die
niedrigsten instanzen die niedrigste
hospitalisierung since i dance
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer
ausgerechnet in sachsen dort wo ja weite
teile deutschlands so viel mit dem
finger drauf gezeigt haben und gesagt
mensch ihr habt so eine niedrigere
impfquote da seid ihr selber schuld
jetzt sind die tabellenführer das
richtig aber gerald gaß hat gerade ja
auch durchaus dargelegt was gründe sind
warum in sachsen plötzlich alles anders
aussieht warum sachsen wie du es auch
gerade gesagt hat der spitzenreiter in
deutschland ist aber generell wenn wir
uns diese hospitalisierung skate
anschauen also weitgehend grünen
deutschen das bedeutet unter dem ersten
kritischen wert überhaupt und wir sehen
ja auch die zahlen wenn man das im
vergleich zum frühjahr 20 21 wir haben
eine deutlich höhere instanz fast
viermal so hoch oder gut dreimal so hoch
wie im frühjahr letzten jahres aber wir
haben eine hospitalisierung rate die
ungefähr nur ein fünftel so hoch ist
auch was die todeszahlen angeht sind wir
deutlich deutlich niedriger als
beispielsweise im frühjahr oder vor
einem jahr also wir sind ja auf ein wenn
man das mal so sagen darf in der
pandemie auf einem sehr sehr guten weg